i'm feeling so overwhelmed with
happiness and excitement
well so are we because gigi hadid is
officially
a mom the 25 year old model and zayn
malik have welcomed their first
child together news first broke in april
that hadid was pregnant
which she later confirmed on the tonight
show starring jimmy fallon
we wish we could have announced it on
our own terms but we're very
excited and happy and grateful for
everyone's
well wishes and support after hadid
confirmed her pregnancy a source told et
gigi and zayn were having a baby girl
adding at the end of the day it didn't
matter to the couple what the sex was
but now they can prepare for the new
addition before she arrives
during a makeup tutorial on instagram
live in may
hadid slammed plastic surgery rumors
revealing she was pregnant during major
fashion weeks earlier this year
people think i do fillers on my face and
that's why my face is round is like i've
had look at their baby pictures
since i was born um i'll just like
but especially
fashion month when i was like already
like a few months prego that's right the
model walked in new york
london milan and paris fashion weeks in
february
and early march all while in the first
trimester of her pregnancy
but then the coronavirus pandemic hit
and things slowed down
a nice change of pace for the in-demand
model mama who spent the down time with
zane and her family
and like especially during this time
it's nice
it's a nice silver lining to be able to
like be
home and together and like really
experience it
day by day gigi and zayn's relationship
status has been off and on since 2015.
when et spoke with hadid in 2016 she
couldn't stop gushing
over her man i met him in person
once before he's obviously so gorgeous
but
really the way that we could have
conversations and we're really
interested in the same things and
it was really easy so that was amazing
and the former one direction member has
the seal of approval
from mama now grandma yolanda he's just
a really good person you know he comes
from very humble
beginnings so he's just a normal guy and
he's a good human being
he's special